CBS News and senior national security in
Oscar and Hamlin was homeland security
and counterterrorism advisor for
president george w bush fran good
morning so glad you're here since you've
been on the frontlines before and know a
lot of the data let's just show this
graphic about where we are in terms of
whether this is a crisis or not it
peaked in 2000 at 1.6 million and it has
steadily declined to the lowest number
ever in more than 45 years in terms of
apprehensions at the border so where is
the crisis so look I the stories that
the president tells the anecdotes are
horrifying right and they appeal to
people's sense of fear in crisis but the
numbers bolide that there isn't a real
crisis right some of this has been sort
of steady state yes some of the people
who enter this country illegally commit
horrific crimes that's not new there is
a role for a border barrier but it's a
role and as part of a larger strategy
you'll recall Norah when we were in
Washington in the Bush administration we
argued for comprehensive immigration
reform and a barrier was part of a
larger strategy and that's what's lost
here right there's no talk about a
larger strategy that's talking about
building a wall but you need there's all
sorts of components you need you need
more medical attention you need more
detention facilities you need more
Border Patrol agents and law enforcement
this is one piece of a larger story so
we are facing an opioid epidemic in this
country we are facing a heroin epidemic
it is the majority of that the
president's right coming from Mexico and
the south
but the truth is that the drugs are
actually coming through legal points of
entry correctly that's right why can't
we strengthen that at the legal points
of entry that's that should be a focus
and this is what I'm saying there needs
to be a larger comprehensive strategy to
address the problem of which a physical
barrier is one small piece friend let me
ask you this you used to order the
threats for the president looking at the
wide landscape of things the president
has to worry about given the emergency
that has been created here all those
stories we just heard the pain that's
happening in people's lives as a result
of the decisions here where would this
rank on the list of threats a president
has to worry about and put his time
attention and emergency energy towards
not
mindless John right I mean look at look
at the rising crisis of anti-semitism
and domestic terrorism in this country
that would be much higher on my list but
we're not talking about that look at the
opioid epidemic that Nora mentions I
mean there's a bunch of things there are
foreign policy crises that I'd put
higher on the list whether that's Russia
China the threats from China
international terrorism Isis Syria I
mean I have a whole long list but this
is not at the table you concerned from a
security standpoint at the consequences
falling out from this government
shutdown particularly at a legal port of
entry which is the airport absolutely
beyond it you know look that stories
that we've heard of workers who were
affected is tragic right on it on a
human level in an individual level but
again from a national security
perspective you've got TSA workers many
of whom are hourly wage who can't buy
groceries can't pay their mortgage and
you worry we've heard stories about them
calling in sick I'll give you another
example so those who protect the
president have monthly requirements to
go to the firing range training right
firearms training right if they're
training that's the first thing to go in
a shutdown because it's non-essential so
how do we feel about him being protected
and all the people who are making the
decisions are still getting paid that's
what I yeah Congress yeah that are
making it or getting paid very
frustrating that's an important context
thank you again as always